Your writing doesn't work because you're
focusing on correctness when what
matters is clarity. My name is William.
I'm an English professor in South Korea.
And for 10 years, I've been helping
scientists, academics, and professionals
turn their knowledge and expertise into
value for readers through clear,
effective writing. And these are the
exercises that have helped my clients
get grants, fund startups, and become
thought leaders in their field. because
all the knowledge and expertise you have
won't make a bit of difference if you
can't write about it clearly. But before
I show you how to practice these
exercises daily, I'm going to show you
what goes wrong with most professional
writing because that's the problem that
these three writing exercises are
designed to solve. If writing is part of
your job, that is maybe you're an
academic applying for funding, a
copywriter writing a sales page, or an
entrepreneur building a personal brand,
then you're used to most professional
writing that sounds like writing. The
writing might not have any mistakes in
it, per se, but it just feels like
there's something that's been labored
over. It's careful, formal, and distant,
and readers hate that. This kind of
writing is autistic. Now, no shade to
the neurode divergent, but I choose that
word deliberately. Atos from the Greek
word for self. Like autists, many
professional writers come across like
they're living a world of their own.
They're writing turns in on itself, and
it shuts the reader out. And when you
read this kind of writing, it's exactly
like talking to someone who is really
nice, has interesting ideas, has lots of
value to offer, but who is missing some
social skills. you have to work extra
hard just to follow along. Like, why did
he say that? How does this connect to
what we were just talking about? Is he
talking to me or is he talking at me?
You're constantly filling in the gaps
that they should have filled in for you.
Autistic writing creates distance and it
makes readers work too hard. That's the
problem. Now, the solution you've
probably heard is write the way that you
speak. And if you're like most writers,
you think that this means to make your
writing sound conversational. So you
focus on surface level tricks like word
choice. Say use instead of utilize, but
instead of however. But this misses the
point entirely. The quality that we
autistic writers need from conversation
is not the words, it's the scene. And
this first writing exercise will teach
you how to anchor your writing in that
scene of conversation so that it stops
turning inward and starts connecting
with your readers. The scene of
conversation is something that we
experience constantly, but we really
notice it consciously. The idea is that
you're with somebody in one place and
both of you are paying attention to one
thing that you can both observe. Say a
blackbird in a tree. So you both know
that you're paying attention to it. And
by attending to it together, you are
engaged with each other. That's what
cognitive scientists call joint
attention. And joint attention is the
difference between autistic writing and
clear writing. The point is not that
you're seeing the same bird. It's that
by looking at the bird together, you and
your companion are inhabiting the same
mental context. This shared mental
context is the anchor of clear writing.
Without it, your writing drifts away
from your reader and back into that
autistic space where only you can follow
what you're saying. So, here's your
exercise. Pick a partner. So, if you're
in a writing class, then perfect. Pick
one of your classmates. But this is
something great to practice with a
friend or your partner at home.
Something I've tried out at home where
we sit having morning coffee. And then
what you do is take turns presenting
some observable details to each other.
Now, you're not just saying, "Look at
that tree." Instead, you present the
details like a gift. So, you'd say
something like, "That oak tree by the
bench has three main branches, and the
middle one curves down and then back up
like a fish hook." Or it could be sound.
You could say, "Listen to that bird's
song. Three sharp notes, then a warble,
then three more notes." With this
writing exercise, the details should be
right there in front of you, easy for
the other person to verify and grounded
in what's actually present in your
environment. We're not using imagination
or inference here. The point is shared
attention. So, you just do this back and
forth for about 10 minutes. You present
something, they present something, and
you get a feel of inhabiting that same
mental space. Now, if you don't have a
partner, you can record yourself doing
this alone. And of course, this is a
great writing exercise. So you could
pick a picture that you're looking at
and just spend a few minutes describing
it as though you're describing the
details to somebody who is sitting right
there beside you. The key is to practice
creating that feeling of shared
attention because that is what we are
going to try to incorporate into our
writing in the next exercise. All right.
So, now that you're not writing like an
autist, let's take it up a notch because
the first exercise was a bit of a
conceit. Professional writing tends to
be a little more complex than sitting on
a park bench pointing at things with a
friend. What if your purpose is
something else to persuade or to
analyze? What if your reader has more
authority than a friend like your boss
or shareholders or a hiring committee?
For your writing to be successful, you
need to make sure that the text matches
the context. This lesson about the text
and the context came up recently with a
graduate student who I'm coaching for a
postgrad position at Stanford. His name
is Yun. And so Yun sends me his personal
statement, which is something like a
cover letter or an admissions essay. The
goal is to provide some context to go
with your CV so that the admissions
panel gets a roundedout picture of who
you are. And Yun's writing was pretty
good. He talked about how he loves
watching YouTube videos about new
technology, which is exactly the kind of
personal anecdote that most guides tell
you to write for this kind of genre. So,
no grammar mistakes and it was more or
less passable if you follow most writing
guides. Yet, it was completely wrong.
So, I asked him, "What does this
actually show about you? Like, what do
you want this to demonstrate to the
hiring panel?" And what he thought is
that it demonstrated his independent
motivation and interest in the topics
that he wanted to study like the latest
tech. But I told him actually what I
think it gets across is that you spend
your time passively consuming content.
See, what Jun didn't know is that at
Stanford, they screen for something
specific called intellectual vitality,
which is the quality that separates
students who just get good grades from
those who are genuinely hungry to learn
and those who generate ideas instead of
absorbing them. And once we understood
that, we approached the personal
statement completely differently. So for
the new approach, we asked a simple
question to make the admissions panel
believe that Yun has intellectual
vitality. what must they also believe?
So, we broke that trait down into
specific qualities and then we found
real stories from his research
activities and life that demonstrated
each of those qualities. So, this new
approach isn't simply a matter of
swapping out anecdotes. Instead, we
systematically mapped out the context.
Now, the context is a network of ideas
and relationships that's basically too
large and too complex to hold in your
mind at once. So, what I like to do is
use this tool to map it out called the
rhetorical planning wheel. This tool
breaks down professional writing into
components that you can analyze
systematically. So, at the center, what
you've got is genre and actions. For
genre, this is the type of a text that
you're writing. That might be an email
to a professor, a research paper, a
white paper. Now, each genre has its own
patterns and functions. And then around
the edge of the genre, you have
components that make up your situational
network. Now, there's a lot here, but
for Yun's case, I just want to focus on
four. And at first, I just want to focus
on purpose and actions. So, when you
think about this, you need to ask
yourself, what are you trying to
achieve? And what are you doing in the
writing to make that happen? So for Yun,
the purpose was to persuade the reader
that he has what they're looking for,
intellectual vitality, and that for the
actions, we laid out a series of steps
that we needed to achieve in order to
make them believe that. Now, for the
writer's role, you need to think about
your relationship to the topic and to
the audience. So to the topic, are you
an expert on this topic? Are you a
posttock who's asking for funding? Are
you somebody who's actually bringing
authority to your sources or are you
relying on secondary sources? Here you
really need to sketch out your
relationship both to your reader and to
the information that you're conveying to
that reader. To the reader, you need to
show appropriate social attitudes. So in
the case of Yun, we needed to walk the
line between confidence in his abilities
without bleeding over into arrogance to
the information you're communicating. Is
it your information? And how confident
are you in it? Now, conversely, for the
audience, you need to consider who's
going to be reading this. What do they
already know? And what do they want to
know? What are they using this text for?
What information are they trying to
find? And where are they expecting to
find it? And the last component that I
want to focus on here is context. So
context considers the text as it exists
in the world, almost like an agent. So
you want to ask yourself what happened?
What event happened in the world that
caused this text to be written? So in
the case of Yun, what happened before
the text and what does he expect to
happen after the text? Well, before the
text, he's just wrapping up. He I think
he's ABD in his graduate program. So he
just needs to finish up his dissertation
and he's applying for posttock research.
And what does he expect to happen after?
Well, he's either going to get an
acceptance letter or a rejection letter.
So this context considers the way that
your document exists in the world and
the the chain of cause and effect that
comes before it and after it. And so
once you map this out, you have formed
what we call your situational network.
It's really important to map these out
before you write a single word because
generic writing advice is useless when
you're writing for professional
purposes. The text must match the
context. And the other thing to notice
here is that when your network is just
you and your friend on a park bench,
then that classic scene of shared
attention is pretty easy. But the
further your network is from that scene
of shared attention, which is to say the
more complex your audience, the more
abstract your purpose or the bigger the
time gap between when you write it and
when it will be read, well, the harder
it becomes to write clearly. And that's
our problem. For most professional
writing, this situation is nothing like
that classic scene of shared attention.
You're not just two friends looking at a
bird. You're an entrepreneur who's
raising seed money. You're a CEO
convincing shareholders of your
viability. And there are real stakes
here. But once you map out your network
clearly, you can start anchoring it in
that classic scene. And that's when you
most need a conscious anchor. And so now
we're going to combine those first two
exercises so that we can anchor
complicated highstakes networks in that
classic scene of shared attention so
that you can write clearly in any
context. And a great example of this
comes from the letters of Jane Austin.
So quick story here. She was writing a
letter to her sister Cassandra who was
traveling abroad. So already we have a
complicated situational network. Jane is
in Hampshire, England, while her reader
is somewhere else, maybe London, maybe
Bath. She's traveled so often that Jane
can barely keep track. And they're not
sitting together on a park bench. Jane
is alone in a room with a paper and a
pen. And they're separated by time.
Cassandra won't read these words for
days or maybe weeks. So, we are a far
cry from that classic scene of shared
attention. But now, listen to how Jane
writes. She says, "I have now attained
the true art of letterw writing. I have
been talking to you almost as fast as I
could the whole of this letter." Look at
that word talking. I mean, she's not
really talking. She's writing alone in a
room. But stylistically, she treats it
as if they're together, as if she's
speaking to Cassandra right there on a
park bench. She takes all the complexity
of her network, the distance between
them, the delay in writing and reading,
the loneliness of the paper, and she
anchors it in that simple scene of two
people talking. This is the trick to
clear writing. It anchors any network in
that scene of joint attention through a
process called blending. So to practice
blending, you take your network, as we
mapped it out using the rhetorical
planning wheel, and you structure it
using the classic scene. So if you have
a distant audience, well, you can write
to one person who's sitting beside you.
If your topic is abstract, you can
present it as something visible, a
blackbird in a tree. If you're writing
about a past event, then you can treat
it as though it's happening right there
before you. So, not saying the tree had
two kinds of fruit, but using the
present tense to say the apple tree
bears two different kinds of fruit. One
green, one modeled, the other red,
fading to yellow. Even if you have a
complex purpose such as persuasion or
analysis, you can still ground it in
that classic scene of showing. So, don't
argue for a policy change. Show the
problem and then show the solution. So,
your situational network is complex, but
the style makes it feel as though you're
both looking at something together. So,
here's the exercise. You take the
network that you mapped earlier, and you
write a single paragraph, but you anchor
it in that classic scene. So, your
distant audience becomes a companion
beside you. Your abstract purpose
becomes something that you're pointing
out to your neighbor here. your complex
content becomes this immediate moment.
You write it and then you read it aloud.
Now, of course, this kind of writing
exercise is going to feel artificial at
first, especially if you're practicing
it alone. And honestly, that's fine.
Practice it until it feels automatic
because clear writing keeps two things
clearly in mind. The anchor of the
classic scene of shared attention and
the network. And writing clearly is
simply a function of anchoring the
network in that classic scene. So you
might be wondering why make such a big
deal out of this distinction. Why not
just write naturally and hope for the
best? Well, because operating in the
dark, you'll float in and out of that
classic scene without recognizing what
you're doing. Sometimes you'll anchor
your writing in joint attention.
Sometimes you won't and your reader
can't follow because you're not
consistent. So the result is a style
that you can't control. But once you
recognize what's happening, that is once
you see how networks get anchored in the
classic scene, then you can do it
deliberately. You can write about
anything with distant audiences,
abstract ideas, complex purposes, and
your reader will be right there with
you, inhabiting the same mental space
and seeing what you want them to see.
That's how you stop writing for yourself
and you start writing for your reader.
In other words, that's how you escape
autistic writing. But communicating
clearly is only one half of expert
writing. You also need something
valuable to write about. So, watch this
video next because it's going to show
you my step-by-step method to use
writing to generate ideas that readers
find new, insightful, and valuable. So,
be sure to go check it out.